♪♪
We don't really
think about it,
it's just always there...
while astronauts are fine
tuned living without it.
If we're going
to inhabit space
for longer periods of time,
it would be nice
to bring it with us.
Can we create
our own gravity?
I'm Wrenn Schmidt
and we're exploring the
science behind
"For All Mankind."
♪♪
We wanted to kick off this
season with an event
that felt like
a ship getting
hit by a tidal
wave in space.
To do that...
we needed the
artificial gravity
on Hotel Polaris
to go haywire.
But first,
why would our
Earth orbit
Hotel need
artificial gravity?
Well, our bodies are
used to Earth's gravity
and knowing up
from down.
If we go too long
without it
we'll suffer some
unpleasant side effects,
like, changes in blood flow,
impaired vision,
and big losses in our
bone and muscle mass.
All to say, we don't want to
make it back from space
with blurry vision
and brittle bones.
So, how could we create gravity?
One way to is to... well, spin.
Rotating at high speeds
generates a force that
effectively simulates
the pull of gravity.
To match Earth's
gravity of 1G,
a ship with a
radius of 735 feet
would need to
spin at 2 RPM,
but a smaller ship
one-fourth the size
would need spin 4 RPM,
twice as fast.
The smaller the radius...
the faster it's gotta spin.
♪♪
The space wedding
is going great,
until the Hotel
takes some damage,
causing it to spin faster.
Increasing the ships gravity
beyond to what humans
are used to on Earth.
1G increases to 2G's.
That feels like
doubling your own weight...
and then it
keeps spinning faster.
3 G's
4 G's
now standing up
isn't an option
and it's harder to breathe
when you're pinned
down on your back.
Fortunately for the guests,
there were some
heroes at the wedding,
who slowed the spin and
saved the day.
We're a little ways off from
generating artificial gravity,
like we see in the show.
For now,
astronauts complete
daily resistance
training to stay
healthy in 0 G.
But if we set
our sights on
making a new home in space,
unlocking artificial
gravity can unlock
new possibilities
for mankind.
♪♪